hang on give me a second I'm getting set
up here huh different room this time
because well I I haven't completely
finished setting up a alternate angle in
the room I'm now shooting the videos in
so once that's done it'll you'll have
something a little bit closer to what
you're used to for this and for the
break room but right now let's relax hey
folks just working out in the yard so um
I need to hydrate i randomness bet you
ten bucks it still turns into Doctor Who
of course it will it always does and
that is not my fault that is your
people's fault uh hi in angry orchard
always a good choice yeah that's a good
default I still kind of prefer woodchuck
but they had this on sale so uh you know
if I can get it at a good price
every orchard works I like it um how are
folks doing like I say you're working
shira's four-wheelers I'm not actually
gonna talk about yard work yard work is
just the reason that this is going up an
hour later than it would normally
speaking of yard work my best friend is
using this time to build a bar in her
garden I like your friend nice new
locations like sharing a drink with you
and your living room
not actually the living room living
rooms on the other side of the house and
actually is a lot harsher light and the
Wi-Fi signals weaker stove this is this
is uh this is actually the room I've
been shooting the very wild videos in
for a while now a new one of which went
up today plug for the other channel one
of the two other channels make sure
these three other channels but one of
them I don't talk about started
replaying Red Dead Redemption to and GTA
five consequent rockstar games they make
dang good games i haven't played either
yardwork I hate your Oregon's
dictatorship for intellectuals see the
thing is I couldn't I mean I don't have
current gen gaming systems anyways so
things like read dead to completely
gonna pass me by but um things like even
gta3 which blew up and everyone loved I
couldn't get into it I just wasn't
feeling the vibe on it I don't know if
it was a tone thing I think part of it
was honestly I didn't like I I tend to
not really liked that much freedom there
you get with the sandbox but oh one
around the city find stuff to do or
might know tell me what to do give me a
project you like it and I mean some
sandbox is give you more directions than
others but just like in general I didn't
love it right off the bat excuse me are
we getting closer to a room tour totally
get it if that's something you're
uncomfortable with by the way well John
um I shot a room tour before I moved my
shooting location to another room um but
that video is a patreon exclusive that's
not something I do very often there's
like three exclusive videos on the
patreon but the room tour is one of them
now that that video is viewable on the
patreon
for any donation level so if it's worth
a buck for you to support for one month
and go and see it you can do that just
solutions with a Big Finish story master
it reminded me a lot of human nature and
the family of blood I have listened to
that what it did that one didn't stick
with me a ton um I don't know what it
was it was okay it was fine I didn't
love it though and it didn't stick with
me the way the best of Big Finish does
boy we got unto Doctor Who even faster
than I expected
still playing dark souls finally beat a
boss after so many attempts so I
proceeded to the next area and proceeded
to kid immediately murder by some people
with sticks that is the darksouls
experience
join the club get good the game I want
to get back into cuz I got as far as the
last boss but I never beat it um was
actually dragging crown
I know then who won't remembers that one
though that was a there was a beat him
up brawler sort of thing I have it on
the ps3 with this super exaggerated sort
of fantasy art style that is very um I
don't know how the sorcerer says top
stays up like that's the art style on
the thing there's a lot of fun and I
enjoyed it I was starting to work build
other characters and I like the the RPG
elements in that game
do you like drinks with juice and vodka
or is beer the best or maybe one beer is
awful
beer said this is hard cider I hate beer
a lot I can't stand it I finally on the
last series of Buffy oh it's worth
powering through for the finale because
the actual finale is good and there's my
short rule 7 a Buffy have you seen the
new Twilight Zone season 2 trailer
I haven't seen any of the first season
of the new Twilight Zone that's on the
pile of stuff that I'd meant to catch
and haven't gotten to yet currently
maintain my ass Animal Crossing island
past 1:00 a.m. Animal Crossing was
another one I never got into I remember
when that first became a thing way back
on if he was on the Gamecube I didn't
get it then I think I get it now but
it's still not really for me I started
uploading videos a couple days ago
any advice um stick to topics that you
enjoy and you will enjoy talking about
regardless of how many views you get and
keep a regular schedule if you can
because if you're just uploading
whenever I can
you're more likely to lose the habit and
drop off the only beer I actually like
is wheat beer hmm speaking of Buffy have
you heard about the reboot they may be
making not in a while it's funny I was
actually talking with Liz about that
this past weekend that I hadn't heard
anything about that in a couple years
now I think because did you see the
Batwoman news no I did not so I don't
know what that is so here was the thing
with Buffy there was talk of a reboot as
a TV series and they were gonna set it
in high school again so basically bring
it back to its original concept and the
part of the original pitch was to have
an african-american Buffy and I actually
think that if you're gonna reboot Buffy
that's a really good thing to do not
just like for the sake of diversity but
because you you have the possibility if
you take advantage of it to give a
completely different high-school
experience because those first three
seasons of Buffy especially it is horror
tropes filtered through the high school
experience but it was filtered through a
middle-class suburban white high school
experience and if you were to filter it
through a more you maybe don't have to
make it urban but you through a black
high school experience
you have the possibility of taking a
different angle for these horror tropes
that you are tackling think about how
being steeped in a cultural
understanding of race affected a movie
like get out I'm not saying that Buffy
should go to that length but I'm saying
informing the way that they tell it
through a completely different high
school experience like that I wouldn't
totally be on board for seeing but I
haven't heard anything about that in
ages so I don't know if that still
moving forward or not Ruby Rose left
that woman before season to start a
production they're going to recast oh
dang I still haven't seen any a bat
woman so I don't know if that's a good
thing or a bad thing but that's
obviously an awkward thing to have to
deal with forget a reboot we need a
Ripper to become a reality yeah I wanted
that too but I gave up I gave up holding
out for that we did need that though cuz
I mean Giles is the best character in
Buffy he just is don't at me well The
Phantom Menace needs something you know
rant about with Shira ending Oh Shira
and me was so good though you know it
was really fun here's what was funny to
me about because I feel it granted a lot
of these channels I don't watch I don't
even keep tabs on but I got the
impression that aside from their initial
little tantrum about um you know the
redesigns of the characters for Shira
and maybe a little bit about the first
season I think most of them dropped off
that because they realized that the
kinds of people who watch the videos
don't care about Shira as a property so
they weren't kind of get more out of
that I know there were like one or two
who continued to complain about it but I
feel like most of them got off it
because they got off of talking about it
because obviously if they continued to
complain about things like Star Trek
Star Wars Doctor Who there are
significant chunks of their subscriber
base who care
those properties pretty sure most of the
subscriber bases of those channels don't
care about Shira
so I feel like that the heat actually
kind of died down a bit over time excuse
me
do you think play I'm not scrolling back
through so if I miss your question you
may just have to ask it again um do you
think plague doctors from the Black
Death arrow will be good for a Doctor
Who story would it be too similar to the
empty child um well I think doing a
plague story right now might be a little
too on the nose
but I think in general it's kind of
surprising they haven't set a Doctor Who
story during the Black Death not not on
the show anyway there's probably been
like a novel or a big finish or
something that has that I haven't read
that picture on your wall is from
Scottish tap a tree of a unicorn which
is Scotland's national animal yes I am
aware and that particular tapestry is
also the inspiration for the opening
credit visuals for the last unicorn so
you know bonus faith forever
I like faith I'm not sure how much have
been to a spin off about her but that's
me though it's almost as if these
outrage margins are just spewing bile
because it gets them views they're
clearly the true heroes oh yes they
sacrifice so much see like usually a big
thing about that it's just something
that they don't get because here's the
thing I know for a fact that going
negative gets you more views my most
viewed videos pretty much are entirely
all ones where I am annoyed complaining
or possibly even yelling and I can I
have the metrics to back up the fact
that negative gets me more views I know
that so I am sure it's the case for
everybody else so I get why you would do
it for a view perspective to grow your
channel
to build a following what I don't get
and what I will never understand is how
you balance yourself it's funny I was
rewatching an older video where I got I
got a bit angry or shouting then like I
would now or at least in terms of the
way in which I directed it but are at
the very end of that video I went you
know I don't like being this angry and
that's very true I can get worked up but
and and like in the moment as a one-off
it can be even invigorating a little bit
but I don't enjoy being in an angry
place I don't you certainly don't enjoy
staying there and even if it's an act
for these channels which I'm not going
to say one way or the other that it is
but even if it is it's God we're on you
to have to just present that much anger
over and over and over and over again
aside from the fact that to quote the
late great curve Vonnegut you are what
you pretend to be are there any movie
tropes or cliches that you enjoy there
are some things I'm a sucker for I'm a
sucker for a character building through
a poker game I'm a sucker for a heist
um there's a handful of things that I'm
an easy mark for that's not to say that
I always loved them cuz you could still
do them badly but I don't hate all
tropes um I'm just tired of a lot of
them
Phaethon spike we're at we're actually
also meant to get their own spin-offs
but they never came through I never
really heard about spike I'm sorry about
faith actually moving for any meaningful
way I know that was something the fans
wanted I do know his spike there was
talk of
actual you know planning being done on
like some TV movies for him to be in but
I don't remember anything tangible about
the faith one I feel like that one was
fan projection mostly most of them use
the fandom topics to spread their
underlying agendas uh well again it's I
I want to be careful cuz I don't want to
bash on specific channels and in some
cases I yeah that's probably true but I
do wonder sometimes how much again in
practical terms it doesn't matter the
difference is negligible but like for
myself I do wonder like how much is of
these these channels where they always
had these points of view and they're
just taking the opportunity to to expose
them more or if they adopted that point
of view because it got the more clicks
you got the more views you have them
more subscribers and more influence
again at the end of the day if you're
pretending to be that video after video
after video for all intensive purposes
you are that but I just for myself I
wonder what came first the chicken or
the egg the idea ideology or the views
what came first one of my favorite
chokes tropes is where team members are
interrogated individually and they tell
wildly different stories for montages of
each I'm a sucker for that's a fun
that's a fun trope opinions on insight
number nine I've only seen the first
series of it I had very mixed feelings
of a sickness owed by EPSA basis some of
the episodes were great some didn't work
for me I ended up not liking some of the
ones that are I guess are really popular
so I was kind of disincentivize to keep
going we've had the war master and Missy
is there any other incarnation of the
master you would like to see a big
finished box set about um well I mean
Roger Delgado but he's gone um and I
know they could get like a sound-alike
but I wouldn't want them to uh so nah I
mean maybe Sasha diwan's
version but I feel like I wanna I want
to see more of him in the show proper um
to get a sense of that have you seen the
fan remastered Seventh Doctor intro no
was not aware that that was a thing by
the way the faith spin-off was in the
works but the actress who played her
wanted to move her career in a different
path so she said no yeah she she picked
up what was her show right after it was
true calling nurse I think was what it
was I never watched it myself
imagine a Doctor Who story themed around
Three Little Indians I don't know if
that was unicorn the wasp I haven't seen
it in a while you know one of the wasps
wasn't I'm assuming you mean there will
be none which is the current name for
the Agatha Christie story that was once
called Ten Little Indians and prior to
that was called something I will not say
on this channel uh-huh but despite
having the idea that Christie story they
didn't actually pull that format the and
then there were none format which I'm
not who has that and that would work for
them for those who don't know what I'm
talking about
this is one of Agatha Christie's most
famous pieces and I think it was
actually originally a play I think so I
know it was a book but then it was
adapted into I've seen it as a play um
but it the set up is ten people on an
island stuck there no communication and
people start dying which means you have
a fixed pool of suspects
none of whom can trust each other
and they just keep dropping so it's it's
a solid format one of my favorite tropes
is man trapped on island or her
wilderness Oh Dan yet it got away from
me hang on man trapped on island or
wilderness learning to survive but
becoming a monster bonus points if
they're rich do you have any new movie
mashups love that video crossing my
fingers Ryan can come back sometime well
I mean we've got social distancing to
worry about now um I don't see like I
love that video too but it's also it's
also a low even at the time it was a low
view count
video um but I didn't have fun with it I
don't know if I have ideas for more
since then the cameras gonna jiggle
because the table I've got this setup on
is not the sturdiest thing in the world
so I apologize for that
my favorite tropes involve people good
people turning bad bad people turning
good I'm a bit of a sucker for good
girls gone bad ooh so my first question
for Ben are you watching Riverdale
I'm not Liz is so I do hear about it any
murder mystery TV shows or movies a
shion's um always kind of a sucker for
law and order if I'm being honest on the
original version SVU didn't do it for me
ah this is all getting away from me now
um have you seen the new control points
video I did was good she always makes
good stuff
spike versus Joan Hart from Torchwood
who would wind
um John would only win if he knows what
a vampire isn't how to kill it if he
does it he's gonna get cocky and screw
up in spite takes him how many minutes
of video do you upload
an average week um well videos from me
these days probably average in the 14
minute range and that's four videos a
week so a little over an hour a week at
present that's going to actually be
shift and that's just on this channel
that's not counting the breakroom or the
bear a wild Channel what are your three
desert island books restaurant Thea into
the universe The Last Unicorn and lamb
the Gospel according to bit might have
asked you this before but will you ever
do a best finales two TV shows list I
don't know
I'm more likely to maybe highlight one
or two specifically and talk about why
those are great the problem is there are
way too many shows that I have not seen
in their entirety and haven't seen the
finales of so that that would be one of
those lists that there's so many
supposedly great ones that I haven't
seen that I would feel like I'm coming
up short to even try and tackle that for
your next Big Finish
I recommend the Torchwood box set sins
of Captain John if you thought miss evil
was met a serious straight-up trolls the
audience um I don't have that one so I
have others that I that I already have
in my possession
now I'm gonna prioritize over that but I
I have heard of that and I am curious
I'm sorry I know you hate hypotheticals
oh boy
what master would you put with Eccleston
in a story for the best and most
interesting result
I'm just gonna say Missy because Missy
should take on every doctor
not heard of Riverdale Oh depends on
your on your here's that here's the
thing Liz it's Liz's current favorite
trash TV and she will blatantly call it
trash and she loves it
there was a live episode of inside
number nine at Halloween without
spoiling it would really it only really
works if you actually saw it live oh
well sorry I didn't see it that but
that's kind of cool that they did that I
won't lie I love a well-written autistic
character but that's probably because
I'm autistic myself well I think we all
love well written characters we can
relate to if there was a there was a
review I was commissioned to do last
year for an episode of a TV show called
accused and it was a it was a episode
about a crossdresser played by Sean Bean
and the thing was I saw so much of
myself and my past experience in that
performance like to a degree that I had
never and have not seen since but had
never seen actually portrayed in a show
before and I broke down a little bit
both watching and in the video review
because it it was a really well-written
and well performed character that spoke
to me in a way that I never thought
anything would so I feel you on that
when you can see something that does a
good job portraying aspects of yourself
you're not used to seeing represented
that can yeah that can be that can be
powerful speaking of murder-mystery
shows have you seen the British show
Jonathan Creek I have not
I've heard of it for what it's worth I
wish you have this chat to behave
okaythat's reminded me of Badu oh I'd
love to see is John Hart and the duan
master Oh which Batman would you want to
see more of the Batman animated series
Batman would be my standard answer if I
still trusted Bruce Timm but I don't
anymore not after Batman and Harley
Quinn holy crap is Torchwood worth
watching children of earth is worth
watching the rest of it I don't love
Torchwood quarantine kisses thank you
Brian and for you losing track of this
whole thing and the latest episode of
Riverdale two boys made a business
selling videos of them tickling each
other such nuanced plot that was like
actually a like a thing like there was a
hole as a documentary made about it that
was like this whole weird underground
thing of men tickling each other videos
which Batman villain would you like to
see the most in live-action someone that
yeah that either has been done before or
not um I would like to see a good poison
ivy in live-action cuz you know I'll
respect to MoMA Thurman and like also to
be fair Gotham gave us a good IV briefly
of the three versions of IV they did
middle IV was quite good I enjoyed her
but she also wasn't like IV as we know
her so I would really like to see
long proper poison-ivy given I will be
finishing Buffy soon I will probably be
moving on to Angel I'll be watching it
anyway but is it any good
yes angel is great and angel here's an
incentive for you to get through it I
would argue angel has one of the
greatest series finales and television I
think it's amazing and perfect love your
shirt thank you
this is actually my own merch so you go
to the T public slash Council of geeks
you can pick this up and the the fist is
padding my own chest here um the the
fist comes in four different skin tones
so inclusion I try to do it
there's a pretty cool poison ivy fan
film I saw the other day with which Eric
Roberts is in it's always weird to be
when they get big stars for the fan
films any baddies of new who you don't
want to see again at all if so I'd like
to know any reasoning there's nobody who
I'd like ban never bring them back again
um there's some that need a rest I kind
of like that the Daleks have been
relegated to the specials
now I actually kind of prefer that that
that works for me might be time to give
the Cybermen a rest for a little bit but
I would still want them to come back at
some point we just you just need to not
overuse them West character arc alone is
worthy
yes Wesley has an amazing character arc
an angel have you listened to the six
musical soundtrack no got to meet
charisma carpenter from Buffy at
comic-con that's cool Oh remember Comic
Cons I do I miss those
you've said you would want the wire to
return here's the thing I would actually
be okay with the wire returning if they
revisited back concept from the ground
up because until she'd evolved into that
crap for the entire latter half of the
episode she was legitimately creepy and
the actress was a perfect casting for
what they were going for and I would
have been interested to see them play
into what they had but they didn't she
just became a generic life sapping
monster thing and like who cares
so I actually wouldn't have a problem
they're coming back provided she was
used better would you rather have the
Daleks used every season or the Cybermen
used with the master every other finale
that is an odd either/or um I guess I'd
rather have the Daleks used every season
cuz I don't want to know I don't want to
be able to call in advance Oh this
year's finale
it'll be Cybermen and the master again
cuz it's time speaking oh the idiots
Lantern hoo boy magpie electricals is
the weirdest recurring Doctor Who in
joke is that a calling thing cuz I
believe you but I actually didn't know
that
yikes I miss cons I had my thirteenth
doctor cosplay all set up it was really
excited naturally everything was
canceled yeah with the exception of the
ending two idiots Lantern do you have
any other major problems with that
episode yes the villain is poorly
utilized the ending is what infuriates
me the most but the character of the
Father in general is he's too cartoonish
for me to get invested in what they're
trying to do with that character and
I've seen people make the argument at me
that there are actually people like that
I'm not disputing that that doesn't make
the characterization any
less cartoonish there are people in real
life or cartoons of cartoonish human
beings that doesn't make for effective
storytelling so no it's got a lot more
problems than the very end the very end
is just the biggest offense that that
episode offers and the only episode of
Doctor Who your kind of drink your way
through this gotta be hell-bent um you
know I hadn't considered the possibility
of doing hell-bent as a drunk review I'm
actually gonna palm to that now though I
was saved from my friend
Kirsty constantly telling me 13 sonic
look like a certain sort of toy up boy
that joke got old real quick
that joke was being made just when a
woman was casting before we saw the dang
thing compiled these amp and before the
flood was from magpie electronics Oh
which upcoming movie would you get back
and would get you back into the theater
again my local theatre would have to
reopen again it's not a question of what
get me back into the theatre it's a
question of the theatre actually being
up and running so wrong question also
the Daleks have to be used in every
season in agreement with Terry nation
estate that is unconfirmed um that has
been a very long-standing rumor there is
no evidence of that aside from the fact
that they have appeared regularly there
is nothing on record of that actually
being the case the BBC does did have to
negotiate to be able to do the Daleks
again but I dug into this a while back
it is not comforting it's possible that
it's possible but that is not confirmed
don't say that like it's fact because it
is not it is a possibility have your or
simon Pegg's Cornetto trilogy of course
i have i have the very unpopular opinion
that Shona Dead is the worst of the
three don't at me
the most annoying thing about my dad is
that his favorite companion is Clara as
he has a crush on our resident oh yes
please more drunk you some things you
dislike your drunker view of cats was
one of the best baby goats love to see
more um I actually got a hey I got a
commission that I haven't gotten to yet
but I got a commission through patreon
that they didn't just want me to review
a movie they very specifically wanted me
to drunk review a movie so we'll see how
that goes hey Freddy just re-watched
name of the doctor and the only part I
didn't like was a constant rhymes of the
whisper men the whisper men in general
are a little bit odd in that I'm not
sure how necessary they are and they're
a cool look but they're just kind of
there I'll pitch you Doctor Who and the
Pirates is the Sixth Doctor
evylyn Smythe deals with similar themes
to Vincent and the doctor and it takes
you away and it's a musical sold pattern
and cartoonish human beings do we dare
name names I'm not naming names use your
imagination
[Music]
immediately adding Council of geeks ha
ha ha look the the Cornetto films it's
hot fuzz end of the world Shaun of the
Dead they're all good let's be clear and
fairness before it worked out I like I'm
sorry can't quite follow your wording
they're both Clara and River were some
baby gay crushes for me even though I
really don't didn't like Clara hey you
know sometimes it crushes our funny
thing because you can crush another like
I really like you but like that can
happen that's legitimate have you ever
seen the Fourth Doctor story the
invasion of time I have not gotten to
that one the only drunker view I would
love to see is one reviewing the Star
Wars Holiday Special
I don't God someone would have to
Commission me to watch that I don't want
to watch that
I'm surprised we've gotten this without
mentioning the time oh excuse me you
know what I it's funny and it's weird
and it's annoying because you know I'm
still working um still working from home
no word on when my company's offices are
gonna reopen um but I've been working
from home this whole time so I haven't
actually had more time or anything but I
have like had you know dreams of what I
would do if I'd had more time I would
love to try and get into actual costume
making and try and make my own Scorpia
cosplay like get some get some foam make
the claws that would be nice I a series
12 DVD includes resolution that's good
I'm glad they've started putting the
specials back on the season sets again
because it started with um day of the
doctor and are actually but time of the
doctor I suppose and they the doctor was
fair enough like that was its own big
deal thing but then they did time with a
doctor as its own standalone release and
then they just started doing the
Christmas specials as a standalone
release instead of having to be part of
the box sets anymore which was kind of
bull crap I'm actually going back to
work at KFC on Thursday help ooh best of
luck I rewatched Rings of Akutan and the
speech with the song dinner really
bother me
I just I can't hear it I can barely make
out what he's saying given out of the
fifth doctor's one of your least
favorites
how was caves of Androzani for you I
thought it was easily one of his best
performances
I liked it well enough last time I saw
it I haven't seen it in a while I'm due
for a rewatch on that
ah the timeless child I'm not going to
talk about the timeless child I'm done
talking about the timeless child I will
probably eventually have to talk about
the timeless child again but I'm not
gonna talk about it now because i no
wanna anything you want to see on Doctor
Who's 60th anniversary something I'm not
gonna make specific request just
something anything will be nice if you
consider reviewing flash Gordon's since
Max von Sydow passed know of all the
maxbox films
dissing jest now that the man's passed
away Flash Gordon no exorcist no Seventh
Seal flash have you made any spontaneous
quarantine decisions my big one was
giving myself a buzz cut I really
haven't like the closest thing was
moving my shooting location from my
bedroom into into a new office room
converting a guest room into an office
but that wasn't that spontaneous I'd
been thinking about it for a little bit
what are your thoughts on the fan series
that Mary Poppins is a Time Lord well
yeah
Mary Poppins is a time Lauren it's Santa
Claus is a Time Lord that it is known
that I don't want to sound so much like
I'm trapped hey we finally got around to
talking about Shira Thank You Ben ah
fascinating
and we saw you on Jessie genders video
the other day love the co.labs add a lot
of fun working with Jessie and I I
suspect we might be doing some other
stuff together down the line as well
have you ever seen any of the Power
Rangers franchise I watched a little bit
of like when it first started that first
iteration but I bailed on it pretty
quick after that because it was too old
for it
hmm well on another topic I kind of miss
Missy and Cara now I miss Missy I'll
always miss Missy I don't really miss
Clara MARY POPPINS versus Missy Missy is
Mary Poppins like that what is she got a
punch of itself in the face did you ever
watch Star Trek discovery thoughts no
thoughts cuz I haven't seen it there's a
theory that in Groundhog's Day Bill
Murray is a Time Lord
so is he it is like a Time Lord in a
broken pocket of time I don't think that
theory holds up and and um Groundhog Day
doesn't need theories it's perfect
leave it alone who is the best Harley
Quinn Arleen Sorkin like what why is not
a question why is that a debate is that
something we will actually wonder who's
the best Harley are these organs the
best Harley Quinn duh character she was
the original voice the character was
literally modeled on her hey this is not
up for debate
what to be completely honest Power
Rangers rpm is fantastic and honestly
really depressing boy that's a pitch
that's what I need is depressing
children's under tainment
thanks what was your reaction to
Michelle Gomez showing up in Gotham um
disappointment that they didn't do more
with her ultimately by the movie she
first showed up was like yes but like
honest
I keep forgetting she was in it Oh Thank
You Carolyn I do need to pop over the
discord because uh random self
promotional plug and reminder etc etc
the council of geeks discord is a
patreon exclusive perk and there is one
of the channels on there is to put
questions in that are guaranteed to get
answered during the live stream although
for that to be worth much I feel like I
need to get worse at keeping up with the
questions on the live stream so that
like it becomes more of a necessity for
people to either drop super chats or use
the discord which means they're
supporting me on patreon I should I need
to get worse at what I'm doing I'll make
I'll make more money that way I can be
cynical ah
let's see question for the live stream
because entrapped ax is the geek
princess are we now
elevated to being Royal Council of geeks
or were we always a Royal Council let's
take it as as a promotion just just
remember the remember that there there
is value and failure because you never
come away empty-handed
there's always data in recent Star Wars
video you mentioned you forgot made the
fourth so technically you forgot my
birthday oh geez I'm sorry sorry
Microraptor I'm not a question but a
thought until I saw the future with them
all grown up
it never completely clicked for me how
young the characters in sheera are
suddenly put the whole story in a
different light like I knew it but
seeing it made it real yeah that's true
actually that is kind of that sequence
is a little odd for that reason not on
in a bad way but in a you forget how
young these uh these characters are
supposed to be
let's see so it sounds like another
doctor who night she loved the Daleks
yeah it always ends up being Doctor Who
please for the love of felines sign off
with Macavity I don't know we'll see if
I remember to do that I know nothing of
she robbed beyond to be into you reviews
though an 80s he managed here I meant
nothing to me so no interest fair enough
I suppose but you don't need an interest
in the original to UM and to enjoyed the
new one from what I can tell she was a
very creative reinvention though any
other similar properties that you think
would be interesting for someone to
explore I would say Thundercats but they
already tried that they only got a
season out of it um transformers has
never really gone away that just gets
continually refreshed and rebooted etc
um and we're getting a new version of
he-man honestly bring back the Real
Ghostbusters sure uh say Matt coming uh
only three episodes and tashera season
vibes so far but the pacing has been
great or prime is really creepy he was
effective as a final villain for the
live screen live stream what kind of
fanfiction do you like can you recommend
something my recommendation for you is
Harry Potter and the methods of
rationality
there's even an audiobook for that I
think it throws people off that I don't
actually read fanfiction I think that's
like a geek requirement that I miss I've
never really read fanfiction so no I
can't recommend anything I'm I'm so
nitpicky
like I remember briefly trying to read
fanfiction in college
like just getting annoyed at everything
like every detail that was that was off
and wrong
I just it would infuriate me and maybe I
was just not reading really good
fanfiction I don't know but like it's
just not something I've ever gotten into
excuse me
two questions aside from using an
external microphone do you have any
advice for getting the best audio and
recording videos are doing things like
live streams or zoom calls um be sure
there isn't too much of an echo in the
room that you're in that's actually an
issue in the office that I'm now
shooting in I need to get some stuff up
on the walls because right now the my
voice is reverberating around a little
more than I would like it to be so I
need to get some stuff up on the walls
to to soften that a little bit other
than that just be sure you know your
microphone settings I know you like
puppets but also know you're rather
picky when it comes to comedies might I
ask your thoughts on Team America war
police I liked it at the time it came
out
I have not rewashed in a long time and
I'm cousin I'm kind of hesitant to
because it strikes me as the kind of
movie that I probably will feel very
different about at this point than I did
when I first saw but I liked it
originally okay and I'm back here with
the main main thing do you think do you
know what another author diary is coming
to give me more of a will to power
through my stories well I've got another
one shot and edited but I want it I try
not to back-to-back them or have them
out too close together on the breakroom
so after maybe another video or two I'll
put that up like I'm plugging away at
them that there will be more don't worry
I like Arlene Sorkin's Harley but a lot
of people didn't like her version now
given how much she has evolved as a
character and isn't submissive anymore I
mean well there you're talking
characterization versus performance and
that's a writing
so if you're asking me who's the best
Harley Quinn from a writing perspective
that's a different question from who's
the best performer who played Harley
Quinn that's a little bit like whenever
I do a ranking of the doctors that's
based off the performances of the
doctors it's not a ranking of the era of
each doctor because you could have an
actor who's good in the part but was
stuck with lousy scripts and so I think
if your question for me was meant to be
who is the best written Harley that's a
different question from who performs it
best Jar Jar Binks is canon the Doctor
Who universe no seriously okay Ben you
can't just drop that you need to explain
that go back to the source and let's
comment on the 60s Thunderbirds videos
pass if that's okay
exactly but people still have a go at me
when I say she was the best well then
those those people are wrong more
thoughts on the catcher Dora kiss um it
worked I wasn't sure it would but it did
Power Rangers rpm takes place in an
apocalyptic world where a virus took
over the world and now rules the Machine
Empire each of the characters has a
backstory episode fantastic show I'm
just gonna take your word on that I'm
still probably not gonna watch it power
to your passion for it that's great
still not gonna watch it if you could
choose to be quarantined in any museum
zoo aquarium conservatory any cultural
institution which one would you pick Oh
I I would have a hard time making a call
between the Metropolitan Museum of Art
and the Boston aquarium
jar jar binks was a member of the Binks
clan whom the tenth doctor described as
being very hospitable and good people
you I consider cross playing and trapped
of a boy that wig oh my god yeah I kick
I've seen some cosplays of entrapped up
some very good ones I tried to manage
that hair I tried to even get it
designed and built and how you would do
it and then moving around with it cool
my agent briefly shut down after I asked
my Flash Gordon question well then you
missed me kind of laughing at you for
the question a little bit uh I feel bad
for having to own up to that petition
for Nathaniel toysreview all the Night
at the Museum movies Kami the Penguins
at the Boston Aquarium the Penguins are
great I really do love the huge vertical
tank though that's the centerpiece of
the thing I love that thing just just
walking around and around it oh it's
great oh do you think the woman at the
end of time was I until something forces
an answer my answer has not changed
since I first saw it I believe it's
Romana and that I'm not gonna offer
evidence that's my head Canon that is
who I choose to believe that it is
because that is what I like to think I
like to think that that is Romana at an
not even necessarily at a later
regeneration but at a much older age and
seeing her and remembering his
connection to her and his teachings to
her and what she brought out of him
helped remind the doctor of who he is
and what he needed to do I know that
Davies is intention was that it was the
doctor's mother except that now that
wouldn't actually be accurate so now it
would just be whoever the doctor thought
was his mother whatever but my answer is
gonna be
that and that hasn't changed since it
first aired have you watched any more of
American Horror Story nope I've not
gotten to it that reminds me of meeting
a Monica from D DLC at a con and
apparently her wig fell off five times
before we met because the week was so
long and heavy wigs look it says I'm not
saying that I grew my hair out
specifically for the purposes of not
having to wear wigs anymore when I
perform burlesque and drag numbers but
it's a really good bonus charge are sent
a telepathic message to George Lucas
perceiving him as an idea for a
character Lucas wrote him into the
Phantom Menace this is on the wiki
Nathaniel wiki is not officially
sanctioned canon material sorry
in your head cannon does Big Finish
count as cannon yes
by and large yes the series six premiere
of the flash they played Flash Gordon
theme while he was running in and out of
a black hole
haha oh if your herd of deer Evan Hanson
I feel like I've heard that I don't know
what that is though or what that means
did you know in the movie King Kong
escapes there was a character called
Doctor Who an Asian actor playing a
doctor and was the villain in the movie
I actually didn't know that I've never
seen that movie but I did know I don't
know why I knew that but I did know that
I will assume you think Flash Gordon is
bad apart from the Queen's or no Rowand
what it was is I've never seen Flash
Gordon first of all what I laughed was
you at your suggestion that to to
remember Max von Sydow to watch that of
all things as opposed to like say the
Seventh Seal or The Exorcist or like any
number of a hundred other things that
he's been in I met Colin Baker at my
local convention to you he was wearing
Crocs if any doctor was gonna wear Crocs
it was gonna be six I assume you know
about dr. Owen King Kong because it
wasn't a Lindsay Ellis fit oh yeah that
is actually where I knew that from good
call dang nice some book forever autumn
wrote about wrote that about Jar Jar I
think I'm not going to count it as canon
so I can sleep at night whatever like
here's the thing about Canon you do not
have to accept everything that is
official canon into your own head Canon
that's the beauty of head Canon oh hey
Jesse did you pop in have you listened
to the Good Omens quarantine and
quarantine edition where Tennessee and
discussed the lockdown as cruelly and
Azir felt No
that's a thing why did I not know that
was a thing Oh Colin Baker's kind of
notorious for wearing Crocs I love it oh
that is great oh just got here you got
here in time for me to be wrapping up
soon but it is good to see you so thank
you have you seen the Sixth Doctor
regeneration by the confession dial they
made a video where it shows how 11 got
the doctors to save Gallifrey um I'm not
sure I've seen that specific one I've
seen something like that
there's a lot of things like that what
would you think about a sheer uh
spin-off where we get Scorpia adjusting
to full-time princess duties and moving
from the muscle mind set um look I love
Scorpio but like I really feel the show
had a very complete ending and I think
you'd be getting very diminishing
returns on any spin-off about any of
those characters and like I say that did
Scorpia is like my heart and soul loved
her to death but I don't I don't I
wouldn't ask for that Good Omens
lockdown was for the 30th anniversary of
the book and early May cool out of all
the lightsaber designs and functions
Canada or non-canon which design would
be your favorite I've always just been
partial to Vader's original to be honest
you should react to the Good Omens
Corrin to do it now do it do it live
we're gonna do it live I'll think about
it
um who's Colin Baker six doctor was
Christopher Walken well remembered so I
am gonna wrap it up ah I hope everybody
is doing all right we did not in any way
stick to the topics that I left out
devolved into Doctor Who almost
immediately next time I might I might
have to put
anything but Doctor Who in the as the
official subject although Donald
backfire on me I'm sure it will uh
anyways take it sleazy yes thoughts on
the Gotham Jim stash it was funny well
while it was there uh so I hope
everybody has a good rest of the day
good rest of the week and um yeah take
it easy take care of yourselves be safe
I know a lot of a lot of states are
starting to reopen but you know just be
careful all right so a quick question
for anyone looking for a drunk movie to
watch tonight anything fun any
suggestions I'm sure you'll get a litany
of them Jesse um yeah
god I wouldn't even know where to start
depends on on what you're feeling no
idea what the time is for you is 2 a.m.
here have a good night yeah it is 9
o'clock where I am so remember that you
are beautiful you are valid and you are
loved
you're the counsel I'm just running the
meetings bye everybody
macavity